في سياق متصل اعلن المتحدث
الاتصال الساخن الذي انشئ عقب ازمه
الصواريخ الكوبيه لا زال قائما في هذه
الاثناء اعلن رئيس مجلس الدومه في فولودين
ان الرئيس الروسي قدم الى مجلس الدوما
مشروع قانون بشان تعليق مشاركه روسيا في
معاهده وقال انه سيتم النظر في مشروع
القانون الذي قدمه الرئيس في الجلسه
العامه لمجلس الدمى اليوم وسيتخذ قرارا
بشانه لافتا الى انه سيتم ارساله الى
الفور بعد ذلك مباشره الى مجلس الاتحاد
الروسي للتصديق عليه
بعد الان من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي اهلا بك
رانيا ما المتوقع من جلسه مجلس الدوما
اليوم
نحن نعلم ازدهار ان هذه الجلسه يعني تعقد
بشكل استثنائي سواء جلسه مجلس الدومه او
مجلس الاتحاد الروسي الطبقه العليا من
البرلمان يعني بدرجه الاولى للتصويت على
مشروع قرار كان قد اعلن عنه امس الرئيس
الروسي خلال خطابه السنوي امام الجمعيه
البرلمانيه وهو متعلق
بالقرار الذي اتخذه بشان تعليق العمل
بمعاهده او معاهده الحد من الاسلحه
الهجوميه الاستراتيجيه مع الولايات
المتحده وعليه فان اليوم وفقا للقانون لكي
يدخل هذا القرار حيز التنفيذ لابد من
التصويت عليه بالاغلبيه في مجلس الدومه
الروسي وهو فعلا يعني فعليا ازدهار يعني
قرار متوقع ان يتم عليه التصويت بالاغلبيه
البرلمانيه اليوم ومن ثم وفقا للقانون
سيتم احالته الى مجلس الاتحاد
ايضا عليه ومن ثم سيدخل رسميا هذا القرار
حيز التنفيذ يعني وفقا لما اعلنت عنه
الخارجيه الروسيه امس بعد خطاب الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فان التعامل مع
الولايات المتحده يعني مبدئيا كما كان في
السابق لم يعد ممكنا بحسب تعبيرات
الخارجيه الروسيه بما في ذلك في مجال
الرقابه على التسليح لاسيما وان الولايات
المتحده اولا يعني تنتهج نهجا معاديا
لروسيا
السياسه الامريكيه تهدف الى تقويض الامن
القومي الروسي وهي يعني اعلنت يعني رسميا
ان من بين اهم
اهداف وايضا يعني يعني لابد من الاشاره
الى تصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
التي تظهر تباعا الان على الشاشه على شكل
عواجل يقول ان اذا ارادت تواشنطن هزيمتنا
سندافع عن انفسنا بكل سلاح بما في ذلك
النووي ماذا نفهم من ذلك رانيا
يعني هذه تهديدات مباشره ازدهار موجهه
للولايات المتحده وهذه هي ليست المره
الاولى الذي يعلن فيها نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي بمتر عن امكانيه استخدام
روسيا للسلاح النووي في الدفاع عن
مصالحها وامنها القومي هنا اود التذكير
ايضا بتصريحات مماثله كانت قد صدرت عنه في
وقت سابق يعني عندما كان الحديث يدور عن
مسمتهم موسكو بتحريض الولايات المتحده
للسلطات الاوكرانيه باستهداف اراضي شبه
جزيره القرم باستهداف الاراضي الروسيه
الاخرى هنا روسيا يعني اكدف انه وفقا
للعقيده الروسيه فانه فان روسيا لن تتوانى
في استخدام كل امكاناتها المتاحه بما فيها
النوويه
لحمايه امنها القومي وفيما يتعلق باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه على وجه التحديد ازدهار
هذا كونوا مرتبط بحجم التهديدات وطبيعه
هذه التهديدات وبالفعل يعني مساله يعني
تعليق روسيا في هذه المرحله المرحله
الحساسه مرحله التصعيد يعني والتدخل
المباشر بحسب تصريحات موسكو الصراع في
اوكرانيا ومحاولات تحويل هذا الصراع
المحلي حسب ما اعلن عنه امس بوتين الى
مواجهه
مواجهه ضد روسيا على الصعيد العالمي
بالطبع هذا له دلالات في هذا اشاره مباشره
ويعني تحذيرات مباشره للولايات المتحده
النموس ان موسكو منفتحه على كل الخيارات
للدفاع عن امنها ومصالحها بما في ذلك
استخدام السلاح النووي مراسله الجزيره
شكرا جزيلا لك